PROFESSOR: How about
the expectation value
of the Hamiltonian in
a stationary state?
You would imagine,
somehow it has
to do with energy ion
states and energy.
So let's see what happens.
The expectation value
of the Hamiltonian
on this stationary state.
That would be integral
dx stationary state
Hamiltonian stationary state.
And we're going to see
this statement that we made
a few minutes ago become clear.
Well what do we get
here? dx psi star
of x e to the i Et over
h bar H e to the minus i
Et over h bar psi of x.
And H hat couldn't care less
about the time dependence,
that exponential is
irrelevant to H hat.
That exponential of time can be
moved across and cancelled with
this one.
And therefore you
get that this is
equal to dx psi star of x H hat
psi of x, which is a nice thing
to notice.
The expectation value of H
on the full stationary state
is equal to the
expectation value of H
on the spatial part of
the stationary state.
That's neat.
I think it should be noted.
So it's equal to the
H of little psi of x.
But this one, we can
evaluate, because if we
are in a stationary state, H hat
psi of x is E times psi of x.
So we get an E
integral the x psi
star of psi, which
we already show
that integral is equal to
one, so we get the energy.
So two interesting things.
The expectation value
of this quantity
of H in the stationary
state is the same
as it's quotation value
of H in the spatial part,
and it's manually
equal to the energy.
By the way, you know, these
states are energy eigenstates,
these psi of x's, so you
would expect zero uncertainty
because they are
energy eigenstates.
So the zero uncertainty of the
energy operator in an energy
eigenstate.
There's zero uncertainty even
in the whole stationary state.
If you have an H squared here,
it would give you an E squared,
and the expectation
value of H is equal to E,
so the expectation value of H
squared minus the expectation
value of H squared
would be zero.
Each one would be
equal to E squared.
Nothing would happen, no
uncertainties whatsoever.
So let me say once
more, in general, being
so important here is the
comment that the expectation
value of any time independent
operator, so comments 1,
the expectation value of any
time-independent operator
Q in a stationary state
is time-independent.
So how does that go?
It's the same thing.
Q hat on the psi of
x and t is general,
now it's integral dx capital Psi
of x and t Q hat psi of x and t
equals integral dx-- you have to
start breaking the things now.
Little psi star of x E
to the i et over H bar.
And I'll put the
whole thing here.
Q hat Psi of x E to
the minus i et over H.
So it's the same thing.
Q doesn't care about time So
this factor just moves across
and cancels this factor.
The time dependence
completely disappears.
And in this case,
we just get-- this
is equal to integral dx psi star
Q psi, which is the expectation
value of Q on little psi
of x, which is clearly
time-independent, because
the state has no time anymore
and the operator has no time.
So everybody loves their
time and we're in good shape.
The second problem is
kind of a peculiarity,
but it's important to
emphasize superposition.
It's always true,
but the superposition
of two stationary states is
or is not a stationary state?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: No, good.
It's not a stationary
state in general
because it's not factorizing.
You have two stationary states
with different energies,
each one has its
own exponential,
and therefore, the whole
state is not factorized
between space and time.
One time-dependence has one
space-dependence plus another
time-dependence and
another space-dependence,
you cannot factor it.
So it's not just a plain fact.
So the superposition of
two stationary states
of different energy
is not stationary.
And it's more than just saying,
OK, it's not stationary.
What it means is that if
you take the expectation
value of a
time-independent operator,
it may have time-dependence,
because you are not anymore
guaranteed by the
stationary state
that the expectation value
has no time-dependence.
That's how, eventually, these
things have time-dependence,
because these things
are not [INAUDIBLE]
on stationary states.
On stationary
states, these things
would have no time-dependence.
And that's important,
because it would
be very boring,
quantum mechanics,
if expectation
values of operators
were always time-independent.
So what's happening?
Whatever you measure never
changes, nothing moves,
nothing changes.
And the way it's
solved is because you
do have those stationary
states that will give you
lots of solutions.
And then we combine them.
And as we combine them,
we can get time-dependence
and we can get the most
[INAUDIBLE] equation.